southpaw is directed by Antoine Fuqua
and stars Jake Gyllenhaal Rachel McAdams
and Forrest Whitaker and is a story of a
down-on-his-luck boxer who has a great
record until something really bad
happens in his life that forces him to
rethink his priorities and try to get
his AGame back again and deal with a
very bad situation that happens and
that's all I'm gonna say because thanks
to you guys I didn't watch any of the
trailers for this movie because you guys
tweeted me when the trailer came out
like hey Grizz don't watch the trailer
for southpaw it spoils so much just stay
away from it so I have you guys to thank
you awesome friggin people to thank for
the fact that I did not get this entire
film spoiler for me because I went back
and watched the trailer after having
seen this film and yeah they spoil
pretty much the entire plot just stay
away from the trailer of southpaw
because this is a very good movie I
think and one that you should experience
without knowing too much because that's
how I experienced it thankfully the
biggest issue that I had with southpaw
is that it follows every genre trope and
cliche of a boxing movie you could
imagine there's the down-on-his-luck
fighter the family drama the big
climactic boxing match the training
montage basically if you replace Jake
Gyllenhaal with Sylvester Stallone and
tone down the language you'd have rocky
7 I mean they're pretty much all the
same but I've said this in my reviews
before if a film is cliched and it
embraces those cliches and it
understands what works about those
cliches and it's well acted and
well-directed and there's obvious
passion behind the project I can get
behind it in southpaw is one of the best
acted movies I've seen so far in 2015
Gyllenhaal again blows me away in this
movie prisoners Nightcrawler and now
southpaw this guy is proving that he is
a master class actor working today and
he commits to this role not just
physically with his body but the
intensity of his performance portrayed
in the ring and the subtlety of the
drama that he's able to create
especially with the actors who plays his
daughter who actually impressed me even
more
this young girl I'm telling you she is
worthy of a Best Supporting Actress
nomination she was magnificent in this
movie never once did I see her and say
oh that's a cute kid performance she's
really trying she felt so passionately
real in this movie and I have to give
her major major commendation because she
pulled off an excellent role you know
what Rachel McAdams also does her best
work in years Forest Whitaker does his
best work in years he's really great as
a person who takes on Gyllenhaal and
tries to train him to get him back up to
speed again and despite all those
cliches fitting into the various puzzle
pieces you probably can predict they
will fit into I was invested in this
movie because of the passion that
Antoine Fuqua put into his directing he
created a very gritty and realistic
world with southpaw and one that was
unforgiving in every way at times in
this movie you will feel quite literally
beaten over the head with the drama and
not in a bad way it pounds you down into
the ground when you witness some of the
atrocities that this man has to go
through it's not overly sappy it's not
melodramatic in my opinion anyway I felt
that it was very real what I was really
pleased with was the way they filmed the
boxing matches I was afraid it was gonna
be some crazy
shaky like zoom in and out shaky cam
but it wasn't it was very well
filmed they used beautiful wide takes
some slow-motion that really got you in
that moment but he had this really
effective way of making you seem like
you were the boxer getting punched in
the face who would actually have
Gyllenhaal or his opponent punching at
the camera and the camera would duck and
move and we even Bob back and forth like
a boxer would and it was extremely
effective it really put you in that
moment you really felt like the dirty
blood and sweat of what a boxer getting
pummeled into the ground would feel like
a guy who's down on his luck who has
family problems probably financial
problems is gonna train really hard and
work really are and you're gonna want
him to win and you're gonna want to care
about him I mean that's basically the
encapsulation of what every boxing movie
ever is and to complain about that in my
opinion is like if you went to the new
Star Wars film in December and complain
that there were too many space battles
or too many lightsaber fights there are
certain things that you know are going
to happen in a movie like this and you
kind of just have to accept them because
that's the way these stories are told
and that's the way these stories work
the best because of the intense and
obvious commitment of Gyllenhaal and
Fuqua in regards to acting and directing
this film I really enjoyed it in the end
and I was wrapped up in the story I'm
gonna give southpaw a b-plus
so if you are to see a new release this
weekend I would strongly recommend
checking out southpaw if you get a
chance to see it also I want to let you
guys know that my promotion with
audible.com is still going on I'm giving
my viewers a free audiobook download of
their choice if they go to audible.com
slash Chris
you can browse their selection and have
a free audiobook on me and audible it's
my gift to you guys I'm always looking
for promotions that allow me to give
something back to you guys I was really
excited to see how much Star Wars
content is actually on that site because
I'm a huge fan of the start with folks I
enjoy reading them guys go to
audible.com slash Chris and you can have
a free audiobook that's it it's
absolutely free my gift to you guys and
my promotional rhythm is gonna continue
on for the next few months thank you so
much as always for watching guys and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck man iced